what's about killing Gunther this is
very cool you think's managed to get
Arnold Schwarzenegger I did to play the
greatest hitman ever yes and then I find
out he wasn't your first choice no
Arnold no no first of all cuz that's an
amazing gat yeah and I find out no you
had other no we were disappointed with
that guy
it was foolishly on my part
reverse-engineered we offered it because
it's it's sort of this reveal at the end
who this villain is but it's hard to
keep a secret when you have Arnold
Schwarzenegger in your movie but we
offered it to Tom Hanks first and got ya
thank you guys thank you yeah pocket of
cinephiles yeah yeah and like it they
reacted to you offering he said Tom
Hanks's name but it got a very very
quick note from Tom Hanks and then and
then offered it to Bruce Willis who
considered it and Bruce and Arnold share
an agent and the agent said Arnold's
looking to do a comedy would you ever
consider Arnold Schwarzenegger and I
said yes yes very much and I couldn't
believe it and it was so surreal and
they're like he wants to FaceTime you
and I was at the offices at SNL and his
assistant picks up like hey I'm gonna
hand you to Arnold now and he's sitting
Arnold sitting at a big desk three times
the size of this one
[Applause]
but he's smoking a cigar and he's
sitting in front of a six-foot tall oil
painting of himself with his
bodybuilding day I love that pretty
great
pretty great that's what I wish I hi
giant painting moon I'm sorry that's
actually kind of what my upper chest
looks like
you